مرحبًا بالجميع ، أصبحت
هيوستن تكساس الآن موطنًا
لتفشي فيروس كورونا ،
وهو إجراء شائع جدًا عند
علاج المرضى الأكثر خطورة بالفيروس ،
حيث يتم استبدال أنبوب التنفس لتحسين
تدفق الأكسجين
إلى الرئتين
المليئة بالإفرازات الجافة من
الرئتين المنتشرة
مع فيروس كورونا ،
يعمل الأنبوب الجديد على تحسين تدفق الأكسجين على الفور
، وهو أول أنبوب لهذا اليوم ، لذلك
كان علينا تغيير الأنبوب
وشخص ما لا يحتوي على أكسجين كان من الممكن
أن يموت أنبوبه كان معطلاً ، وكان
لديه بالون صغير في النهاية
كان  تمزق لذا لم يكن يحصل على
ما يكفي من الأكسجين ،
المركز الطبي التذكاري الموحد ، مستشفى 117
سريرًا يخدم مجتمعًا معظمه من الطبقة العاملة
في
شمال هيوستن في الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية ،
لقد رأيت حالات
دخول ومرضى أكثر مرضًا مقارنة بالأسابيع العشرة السابقة ،
لذا فقد كانت
زيادة هائلة في
شدة المرض
وعدد الحالات
التي قابلناها تتوسع الوحدة المرغوبة
إلى أبعد من العناية المركزة  الوحدة عن طريق
تحويل أقسام كاملة من المستشفى
إلى غرف مؤقتة محكمة الإغلاق ،
مما يخلق مناطق ضغط سلبية للحفاظ
على الفيروس المحمول جواً
يتحرك ويخرج من المعدات الواقية الآن
وفيرة لدرجة أن كل شخص يضاعف ثلاث مرات
بعض الموظفين الذين يحصلون على ثماني
مجموعات
أو أكثر من PPE في وردية واحدة
في  مائة يوم كانوا
يعالجون مرضى فيروس كورونا ،
فقط ممرضة واحدة أصيبت
بالمرض
الذي تعالجها الآن من قبل
زملائها ، أنت عامل الخط الأمامي
في المعركة ضد كوفيد ، والآن
لديك ،
نعم ، وأنا لا أتمنى ذلك  هذا على
عدوي هو عزل المرض الذي
يصعب التعامل معه حتى بالنسبة لشخص
يعرف ماذا يتوقع أفكارها الآن مع بناتها اللائي يبلغن من
العمر تسع و 10 سنوات ماذا
ستقول لمادلين وأبيجيل الآن
الأم الصغيرة تحبك والسيدة لك
أتمنى أن تقضي وقتًا رائعًا في
كاليفورنيا ،
حسنًا ،
لقد انتهيت ، لقد أصبح الدكتور فارون الذي عمل الآن لأكثر
من مائة يوم دون
توقف نوعًا من التعاون  أخصائي فيروسات الرونا
في هيوستن ، هناك نوعان من
المرضى الذين قاموا بتقليدهم
وأولئك الذين سيتم نسخهم قلقي
كمقدم رعاية صحية
هو أنهم عندما يمرضون لا
يأتون إليّ جميعًا في نفس الوقت وهو
ما يحدث في  في الوقت الحاضر
وهذا ما سيقتل المرضى
لأننا لا نملك الموارد الكافية